five the joker does have rage
oh when does the race drive coming there
it is pushes him towards the wall let's
give you a hard comeback here unless he
can get a big mitt oh nice block on the
low
oh my gosh oh my gosh
round three
four
come on i've never noticed that well
really yeah look they're pulling them up
you'll see it they're grabbing them and
pulling it off i don't know i've never
noticed that before
but how do you know it's a stuff i have
no idea but as i have no idea it looks
like this combo
what the hell's going on i don't know
ah he had to try he had to try something
there to stop the momentum the super
camera with the first round three
bro he ain't gonna go he's not gonna get
the wall he's [ __ ] the other one oh
no
oh
here we go
he's alive 30 seconds left on the clock
i don't think it's going to be dead but
it's going to be very close
ah
what's going on
down back 4k which is going to take over
super cooler two
yeah to throw
nice okay one more hit
oh
damn jab
what's up oh my gosh this is the black
cause i'm amino wait you're out rager
right drive
oh
i thought what's gonna happen
i don't know
step two black kazama with the clutch
one
oh that hurts
[Music]
grand finals has everything
[Music]
[Music]